les mesures préventives qui ont été
imposées par le gouvernement du québec
pour faire face à la première vague de
kobe 19 ont-elles vraiment été efficaces
et des consignes actuelles pour contrer
cette deuxième vague sont elles utiles
le défi 28 jours on est devenu un de 56
jours un confinement sans promesse de
faim pourtant les hôpitaux ne déborde
pas pourquoi poursuivre et à quoi ont
servi nos efforts du printemps on veut
comprendre
on devait plonger dans les chiffres on
l'a fait avec mathieu maye giroux un
chercheur de l'université mcgill
ces modèles guident les décisions du
gouvernement du québec et avec lui pour
comprendre on revient au commencement à
la semaine de relâche on voit qu'on a
vraiment 12 dates où il beaucoup de cas
le 8 et le 15
si l'arrivée du virus au québec en bleu
le retour des premiers voyageurs
infectés connus environ 80 reviennent au
dimanche 8 mars et près de 300 le 15
mars
nous fermerons nos frontières aux gens
qui ne sont pas citoyens ou résidents
permanents du canada dans la semaine du
16 mars les frontières canadiennes ferme
et puis c'est la 14ème obligatoires le
nombre de cas importés diminue mais le
virus est entré au québec
la propagation des mares et en un mois
on passe à plus de 1000 cas par jour
à ce moment là personne ne savait à
quelle vitesse se propager le virus mais
aussi aujourd'hui que sans restriction
une personne infectée en contamine en
moyenne 2,5 autres ont dit que le taux
de reproduction
le r et de 2,5 en d'autres mots en tout
il est entré en mars
mille cinq cent quarante quatre
personnes affectées au québec si on les
avait pas confiné elle aurait infecté en
moyenne chacune 2,5 personnes ça fait 3
1860 puis 9650 puis 24 1125 puis 60
mille trois cent douze personnes en cas
de transmission ce type de croissance
rapide et dit exponentielle
c'est cette menace qu'inquiéter les
scientifiques dès le départ on a tous eu
peine à y croire
pourtant cette courbe on la voit dans
plusieurs pays
au québec au printemps on a évité la
courbe exponentielle éviter des dizaines
voire des centaines de milliers
d'infections
mais comment on peut comprendre ce qui
s'est passé grâce à ses autres données
en rouge les hospitalisations
quotidienne avec plus de 100 par jour à
son pic
on peut en déduire le moment
approximatif de la transmission est
alors connaître la vitesse de
propagation du virus pendant toute la
première vague dans les années puis de
myologie qu'au québec pour chaque
personne qui est hospitalisé on ne le
moment où l'on à laquelle ont développé
des un temps où tout début le virus se
propage avec peu d'entre av
le r est autour de 2 conséquence la
semaine suivante les hospitalisations
grimpe en flèche la semaine du 16 mars
québec ferme universités écoles
garderies immédiatement la propagation
ralentie autour de 1,7
le nombre d'hospitalisations par jour
augmente encore mais plus lentement au
23 mars les services essentiels sont
maintenus la propagation freine 1,4 puis
à partir du 13 avril
elle est en dessous de 1 l'écart diminue
globalement les mesures prises ont ont
vraiment réduit le nombre de nouvelles
hospitalisations et ont permis de garder
le taux de transmission en mode 1 sur
une période soutenue de plusieurs mois
qui a permis de vraiment cassé la
première vague mais aurait-on pu faire
mieux au printemps au total six mille
deux cent cinquante personnes ont été
hospitalisées si on avait retardé les
mesures d'une semaine il y aurait eu
douze mille hospitalisation deux fois
plus en agissant une semaine plus tôt on
en aurait eu deux fois moins autour de
et moins il ya de cas moins longtemps
dur la vague et donc les mesures
restrictives plusieurs semaines de moins
selon ce modèle marge d'erreur c'est
certain mais je pense que
qualitativement on se trompe mais il
aurait fallu agir alors qu'il n'y avait
qu'un ou deux cas par jour
c'est ça vraiment un des problèmes avec
la santé publique
c'est que si on agit trop tôt la
population ne reconnaît pas le problème
le col nombre de corps une fois qu'ils
me doivent mettre en place vont pas
nécessairement augmenter beaucoup
puis on la population doit se dire en
juin c'est le déconfinement on relâche
pourtant le nombre de cas ne mentent pas
on s'est tous demandé pourquoi
qu'on est allé à l'université laval voir
marc brisson il détient une partie de la
réponse
une augmentation graduelle des capacités
de dépistage à partir de demain
deuxième élément c'est que à l'été le il
y en a moins eu de contact parce que les
gens ils sont en vacances avant la
qu'ovide les québécois voyaient en
moyenne 7 8 personnes par jour sans
protection à moins de deux mètres
pendant le confinement en avril et mai
ce nombre est descendu en moyenne à 3
par jour en juillet malgré le
déconfinement on y restait prudent à
environ 4 contacts rapprochés
le calme de l'été est aussi dû à un
autre changement important
le 18 juillet après beaucoup de
tergiversations québec rend le port du
masque obligatoire
on ne connaissait pas encore tout à fait
l'efficacité mais maintenant on en
connaît un peu plus en regardant ce qui
s'est passé en ontario entre juin et où
34 régions ont imposés successivement le
port du masque à différents moments dans
les semaines suivant leur introduction
les chercheurs ont observé une réduction
de -25 % du nombre de cas mais en nous
on baisse la garde sans conséquence
apparente les contacts reprennent
graduellement en particulier chez les
jeunes et les enfants avec le retour à
l'école tranquillement ça s'est mis à
augmenter
puis on n'a pas agi pendant longueur
d'onde le on avait 46 cole lundin 24 ou
et cac 40 c'est ce que personne n'a pas
de l'attraper vraiment comme c'est
exponentiel ça mentalement très vite qui
on a atteint le 1552 octobre tous les
bars casino reste pour le 1er octobre
le gouvernement annonce de nouvelles
mesures d'urgence sont allés dû fermer
mais avec seulement quelques dizaines
d'hospitalisation par jour comment
justifier de telles mesures
encore là c'est les courbe exponentielle
sais que ça va pas rester à 50 que ça
peut on peut perdre le contrôle
facilement même si on reste à 50 par
jour un moment on va les valeurs
on va frapper la capacité l'on peut
augmenter la capacité on peut le libérer
ça veut dire que des gens qui n'auront
pas de la chirurgie des traitements ou
de dépistage pour le cancer cancer qui
n'ont pas frappé des gens vont pas
mourir ducobu chaque semaine
mathieu maye giroud fait les projections
du nombre d'hospitalisations au 7
octobre cette projection pour le
prochain mois le préoccupe
au québec on a près de 1800 lits sur les
étages et environ 400 sont déjà occupées
par des cadeaux qu'ovide si on maintient
nos habitudes de septembre on aurait
plus de 25 % de risque de dépasser la
capacité même chose aux soins intensifs
on a 380
il le risque est aussi là ça se peut
qu'on atteigne les limites des
ressources humaines avant qu'on atteigne
le mérite de lutter en fait le système
est très fragile à cause des ressources
humaines
les mesures du 1er octobre ont fait
chuter la transmission on a évité le
pire pour le moment mais depuis fin
octobre
le r remonte au dessus d'un c'est à dire
qu'une personne affectée contamine plus
d'une personne en moyenne
l'épidémie recommencent à croître une
augmentation qui coïncide avec les
relâchements des mesures de
distanciation max brisson et son équipe
l'observent dans leurs sondages à
montréal voici les hospitalisations
enregistrée en début octobre
l'adhésion aux mesures de distanciation
est bonne la courbe a fléchi mais on
atteint un plateau fragile où le moindre
relâchement fera basculer la situation
cette semaine marc gris sont présentes
de futurs possibles
1 si on maintient les mesures du 1er
octobre fermeture des bars et
restaurants précaution à l'école et que
la population respecte la distanciation
et le port du masque en réduisant de 25
% ses contacts par rapport à septembre
les hospitalisations diminue lentement 2
si la population relâche et reprend le
rythme des rencontres de septembre
les hospitalisations se remettent à
croître
en région selon les enquêtes de marc
bressant les mesures de distanciation
ont été moins respectés qu'à montréal
dans certaines régions comme aux
saguenéens en estrie en mauricie
le nombre de cas est en croissance
depuis le printemps nos efforts ont
sauvé des milliers de vies seulement au
québec c'est dur à croire mais les
modèles nous aide à comprendre comment
il permet de dépasser nos intuitions
souvent trompeuses mais ce n'est pas
encore gagné
tout peut encore basculer permet des
restaurants fermés des commerces fermés
dès des secteurs de l'économie infligées
à la population des sacrifices sur le
nombre de contacts qui peut y avoir
lorsque les problèmes des hôpitaux il ya
pas de décès puis le nombre de cas est
détectée est faible politiquement ce pot
payant mais c'est ce qu'il faut faire
d'un point de vue santé publique
fois j'ai le plus vite possible parce
que ça permet de maintenir les
interventions durant moins
[Musique]